hey how's it going BR this
is and today we're going to play some
with the ocals and the motion leap good
times it's going to be a good one yes
first game you play as a kitty I'm
curious how this is going to
work how to play play with toys increase
perometer to level up enjoy cat life oh
look it's my paw it's my other paw
they're like snakes coming out of my
face I'm
like it's working what is this
[__] trying to patronize me
[Music]
game that's
amazing
yes woo yeah yeah W best
game this is the
future it's working so badly seriously
what the [__]
I bet this game was made by cats
seriously shame on
[Music]
you world of
commus oh my God there's my is that my
hand that is my hand
wow wow okay this is [__] awesome I
love this this is giving me a weird
Direction I got to
say
what the [__] am I
doing oh
okay there it
is hey
buddy what the [__] this is so weird let
me touch them
titties
oh
God ah ah oh god what
happened I did not ask for
this uh got to put them over there there
we go let's go for the heart
[Music]
baby this is so [__] weird
Bros
what I entered the blood cells what a
magical way to learn about the
world oh this is freaking me the [__]
out can I go back
please yeah I'm going back [__]
that to oh God no no no
back back this is too weird for me all
right what else do we got
let's take the universe this is like
drugs I I don't do drugs but I imagine
this is what drugs feels
like like what the
[__]
science
science what the
[Music]
[__] boom boom boom
[Applause]
yeah shut up don't tell me I fa
[Music]
him pick the [__]
up
oh shut up sh shut up
stop
my
God this is why there's evil in the
world come on [__] hell [__]
you what yes slap that booty baby slap
that booty baby uh uh booty baby
[Music]
uh oh oh oh oh feeling
it combo baby every day every day every
night every night forever I for I love
you I
need [__] [__] game
[Music]
ever smack
booty [__]
[Music]
[__] repeat the incision just above the
hind select the four Subs pick the
Triangular flag of the muscle just above
the for limbs with the
fors what the [__] are those things
then oh no closeup please the ball get
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa everyone calm
down calm down I did not ask for this I
did not my
[Music]
this llama with a beer no beer with
llama so it says control the llama with
your hands try and keep the balance
don't drop the beer
got it here we go no are you
serious clap pants to restart
[Music]
okay stupid piggy what are you looking I
love the collap
[Music]
restart oh my God I hate
you
[Music]
again yes all right BR hope you enjoyed
this video look out for
more now see in the next
what br I'm trying to not get it all my
C really it you could just take a bacon
strip put some toothpaste on it and